the big thing of course all of last week
is this don't say gay bill here in
florida and of course the word gay is
not in the bill you are allowed to say
gay gay gay gay you can say gay you can
dance down the hallway in a school
singing gay you can do whatever gay
stuff you want to do nobody really cares
they just don't want you doing it in
their face which i think is a very fair
premise
the bill is called hb 1557. here's just
a couple of the bullet points that we've
shown you a few times so in essence what
this is about is they don't want
kindergartners to third graders to be
taught about gender identity or
sexuality if a kindergartner or third
grader walks in and says i have two
mommies or two daddies you are not going
to be kicked out of school they are not
going to not allow your parents to come
to the play where you're the lower
incisor in the tooth play or anything
else this is that they don't want these
discussions happening
in school let's just pull up the bullet
points one more time real quick uh the
other things that are the little more
specifics and i know i've gone through
this but it's worth repeating just real
quick we'll knock out the five of them
but they want to notify parents of
changes to health or well-being of
course you would want that they don't
want to encourage withholding of info
from parents why should a state
government school be allowed to do that
allow parents to access child student
records of course that makes sense let
parents refuse school health care
services sure and get parental
permission for health screening these
are all obvious things that we all know
we all know them to be true and there is
no first grader out there that thinks
that they're closeted or the wrong
gender that should be able to talk to a
parent a a uh
a teacher and then hide that from the
parent we all just know this this is the
sheer lunacy that they do with
everything but so desantis is signing
the bill this is happening people are
going bananas every mainstream thing
everywhere don't say gay well now disney
disney which is the the woke corporation
that does plenty of business in china
and has no problem uh with their
concentration camps for the uyghur
muslims and has no problem with how they
you know do their sneakers with nike in
the in the factories and all that stuff
but disney's really really good they're
really really good as they propagandize
all of their woke movies to everybody
and they've ruined star wars and
everything else
um
disney is uh had a sit down the ceo of
disney had a sit down with ron desantis
and basically he was trying to say to
him hey you better do what we want and
you better not sign this bill and
desantis was like no
he was he just flat out said it no i'm
signing the freaking bill we showed you
the video on friday where desantis gave
a speech afterwards saying we are just
not going to bow to woe corporations and
i am the
chief executive of the state of florida
i am i am uh the guy that is supposed to
do what's right for the people of
florida not what's what's apparently
right for a giant corporation disney
here's a tweet from gavin newsom he is
the evil
monster who is running california the
state that i fled he now wants disney to
come back to california disney the door
is open to bringing those jobs back to
california the state that actually
represents the values of your workers
now first off of course because i
mentioned california i've got to put
some money into the california fund and
somebody in the locals community i will
pay cash money to to leave california
and move to florida at the end of the
year now gavin newsom who he's just an
evil psychopath um he closed disney for
most of 2020 and 2021 uh put a whole
bunch of disney workers uh out on the
streets close up the schools you know
all the stuff so he ruined california
disney but now he's saying we'll take
you back now he may close them again
because coveted two is coming obviously
like this this was just the test run
there's obviously going to be a covet
too um so gavin newsom you're just evil
and by the way disney's not gonna leave
florida what disney then did do which is
this is so hilarious it's so it's so
wonderful so i saw all these blue check
people saying how could disney give
money to the evil republicans and how
could they give money to these evil
florida legislators voting for this so
you know what disney decided to do
they're not giving any money to anyone
in florida anymore that's right and it's
like good zippity-doo-dah i believe
that's a phrase from a disney movie
zippity doodah zippity a my oh my what a
wonderful day yeah you did it disney
thank you so and then they they
criticize
uh desantis for this like oh see he's
not even gonna take disney's money
anymore oh so our politicians are not
going to be bought off by giant
corporations this is good
so disney's money will not go to
democrats or republicans in this state
anymore spectacular
wonderful hallelujah and by the way ron
desantis is right because parents
as he said on friday parents
don't want their kids indoctrinated with
this stuff and parents you're not going
to believe this bring their kids to
disney so i think he's on the winning
end of this stick
well desantis also isn't taking it that
he put out this spectacular video on
twitter a couple days ago this is just
great just firing back on
uh the media and how they lie and lie
and lie and lie about everything but in
this case don't say
gay
ron desantis has taken a stand and said
no you can't acknowledge that gay exists
at all is discriminatory uh a form of
bullying or a so-called don't say gay
bill don't say gay bill don't say gay
bill
does it say that in the bill
does it say that in the bill
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it's why people don't trust
people like you because you peddle false
narratives disney ceo bob chapek
weighing in on that florida bill the
company has been opposed to the bill
from the outset the chance that i am
going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights simply because of
fraudulent media narratives or pressure
from low corporations the chances of
that are zero
how do they possibly explain
lining their pockets with their
relationship from the communist party of
china
because that's what they do and they
make a fortune and they don't say a word
our policy is going to be based on the
best interest of florida citizens
not on the musing of preparation
he could have just ended it there by
saying our policy is going to be based
that could have been the end of it you
know based this is you can either be
woke and if you're not woke and you're
really fighting it the right way as i
try to do here you are based that's what
the kids say michael is that what the
kids say i always ask michael for what
you got any other phrases that the kids
are saying these days
base is good all right give me another
one tomorrow i want to know what the
kids are saying um that's how you fight
back that's how you fight back you don't
take it lying down